welcome back to the rockstars i'm phil
molina and this is fitness origins it's
a little fitness competition show where
i use the films
of the mcu to inspire my fellow nerds on
their way to becoming superheroes
if you've been following along you know
that we're now up to iron man 3.
now in taking inspiration from that
movie i originally considered making
this week this
incredibly elaborate plan all about how
they thought i was their friend philip
molina but actually i've been some
british actor for
all of the 15 years that i've known
these guys and the real phil molina is
actually
guy pierce or something but
unfortunately i can't do a british
accent if
me jim please what's all this
crikey no forget yeah i can't so instead
i scrapped that idea and i came up with
this
hey guys hey iron man 3 he has a lot of
suits so i'm giving you 100 bucks to buy
some clothes
what for real this is the best week ever
this is so much easier you know how much
i usually spend on clothes you just
bought me a wardrobe for the next five
years
okay now legitimately here's why i
wanted you to get some fresh trip it's
cuz you're at week
four of this challenge which means you
are now at the end of phase one
technically iron man 3 is the beginning
of phase two
and not everything in this is gonna line
up with the mcu i mean it's the end of
phase one of your fitness plan
we are a third of the way through which
means it's almost time for you guys to
push yourselves up
to the next level but also i want you to
finish
phase one with your strongest
performance yet okay
here's how we're actually gonna push you
guys a little harder this week
so aldrich killian came up with
extremists if you remember in iron man
3. it was a way to give some ordinary
people this extraordinary power by
having them focus on getting their body
heat
way hotter than usual for our purposes
we can think of that as your caloric
burn rate so for the two of you and
anyone watching at home actually there's
one proven way to maximize that burn to
any time you're exercising
you make sure you stay for the entirety
of your workout inside of your target
heart rate zone
eric you remember this uh from the joys
of last week's challenge
i feel like this is just punishment for
you it's hard to do math while you're
also doing physical exercise you
understand why jocks and nerds
fundamentally hate each other on a
natural level well to simplify it for
you
and tommy who is a jock nerd uh and the
rest of the people watching let's go
just put the formula up on screen now to
find your target heart rate zone you're
only going to need to look it up once
and then it'll apply for the rest of
your workouts and i know it seems like a
simple concept at least but if you are
watching your heart rate the entire
workout and you do keep it in the zone
you actually get killer calorie burn
rates all week long so in addition
to tracking your workout consistency
this week i'm also going to be assessing
who burned more calories compared to
themselves
last week basically this week's
challenge is about which of you two
hunks is gonna have the hottest bod
as measured by literal caloric burn due
to body heat transfer how are you gonna
keep track of those calories babe
uh because you both have fitness devices
that you now wear right
right so uh based on the amount of time
you exercise and your heart rate during
the exercise we're going to be able to
actually calculate caloric burn
after each exercise and compared to what
we have for you from last week so go
ahead and go put your order in for some
new clothes for these hot hot bods
you're going to have and then
all week long make sure to keep that
heart rate in the zone
if it does fall below 50 i'll blow up a
bus
no have a good week
day one we're back at it i'm feeling
very good but the universe as
always is conspiring against me because
my roommate made brownies
why would you do that to me so i'm
already burning more calories than i
would normally do just to try and win
this week but now i have to burn even
more
so that i can eat these brownies i'm in
a tough spot here folks pray for me
i feel like tony stark i make this look
good
that's a men in black it's a different
franchise i was able to get
a new shirt that actually you're
supposed to work out in this kind of
fabric and some
new gym shorts because i only have two
pairs of gym shorts and
socks feels more athletic i feel like
the clothes are hanging on me lighters
feel
like i am someone who works out
so this was plank day and because the
theme is iron man 3
burn burn baby and you feel the burn
right here
and you feel the burn right here and you
feel the burn here i really wanted to
show myself that i could last longer so
i doubled all the times
epic hero fitness gave us money to get
some new workout clothes those clothes
arrive today i'm gonna walk you through
what i bought
tony stark gets all his cool tech
they're all iron man suits they're
similar but they're all different so
that was what i did with these purchases
an essential for me dry fit t-shirts i
got the captain america blue here
i've got the spider-man red here gray
put your own hero there this is kind of
like a thor blue i think that's nice i
got some gray
and black champion sweatpants i also
bought this black headband because my
hair is out of control
thank you epic hero fitness so this is
the worst day
but of all the days of the week this is
the one where my heart rate is going to
be the most challenged
15 minutes eight different exercises
with a minute rest in between
but that minute goes by real fast
halfway through my goal here was to keep
my target heart rate
between 120 and 140. i think after i was
doing the high knees i was clocking in
around 130 or so
after the jumping jacks i was getting
140. and then i think i peaked after the
mountain climbers it's proud of myself
for getting through all those plank leg
raises because i could have taken a
break disembodied philip here eric
started out the week with a goal of
staying in zone
1 roughly 120 to 140 beats per minute
but honestly
a month into these workouts and he's no
longer at the beginner level
so after we talked i bumped him up to a
goal of zone
two and honestly i'm just so proud of my
boy oh
okay come on come on come on buddy but i
i powered through i wanted to really
feel a burn i wouldn't feel like an
extremist
explosive test subject yo brownie update
i'm on my way
went to check the plate of brownies and
it looks like bang
somebody ate one but that's okay i'm
still gonna get the 1200 calories out
so i can enjoy the brownies at a later
date let's get it this is the first time
i did a whole bunch of mountain climbers
and didn't end it by scrubbing
oh
checking in on my resting heart rate i
was way higher today than yesterday
which surprised me
right at the get-go i was over 150 and
then i stayed between 160 and like 175
i was locked into that zone two this is
the moment of truth we've worked
very very hard to get to these brownies
there's a few less
than we're there the last time i'm a
little disappointed in that now i have
worked my
butt off to burn 1200 extra calories
to eat these brownies and i gotta say as
i'm looking at them
i don't think i can do it guys i worked
my butt off to burn 1200 calories this
is what i've been doing my whole life is
like
working out to reward myself with bad
food and now i want to work out to
reward myself by feeling good so
they're going in the garbage oh god i'm
not getting out of the garbage am i
good afternoon you two hotties i don't
just i mean your appearances i mean your
metabolisms i've been keeping up with
your extra calories brenda this week
eric i've been checking in on your vlogs
how'd you do how did your heart rate
zone uh
setup work out actually it was really
helpful to keep track of my heart rate
but it's really easy for me to get up to
zone 2 and zone 3 than i thought so i
kind of
i'm trying to keep it within the
confines of it but by just counting that
i really got a lot out of just applying
a metric to it because i feel like
oh i'm actually achieving something
metrically yeah it's like points
you're gaining points but also you're
burning way more calories than you would
have normally by letting yourself leave
the heart rate zone
tommy did a great job showing that this
week he and
dude very great job not cashing in all
those calories to
to have that plate of brownies i'm very
impressed with you
no problem i just honestly it was uh
some hard work where i just
realized i didn't need the whole plate
of brownies and tummy
uh-huh yeah you
you very obviously have chocolate in
your teeth oh
well yeah some medicinal chocolate for
my post-workout you know a lot of did
you guys did you eat the plate of
brownies
no no no no no no i ate just a tiny
little piece
of chocolate sent to me from my mom as a
bit of an encouragement
no okay okay okay it really it was just
like a chocolate coin that your mom sent
you
that's right yes i'm sorry i yelled at
you that is
much much better than an entire plate of
brownies good job man you're thank you
seriously letting him okay all right
okay
noted i will remember that thank you
phillip
yeah yes you know cheat meals are
are super important for your mental
health and your willpower while you're
doing this
having the saturday night restaurant
dinner to look forward to
that helps you get through monday
through friday and all the healthy meals
remember that doordash connects you with
the absolute best cheat meal restaurants
right now to your door near me
they got a baskin robbins real close
they also got a five guys they also got
a cheesecake factory that entire menu is
available to me it's not even getting to
the 75 different kinds of tacos that
exist in los angeles that could be
inhaling right now at this moment well
if it were my cheat meal time but it's
not guys ordering is super easy open the
doordash app
choose what you want from where you want
items are safely dropped outside your
door with contactless delivery so you
guys get 25 off up to a 10
value and zero delivery fees in your
first order but we look really good to
doordash and they're happy with us when
you use it
so please download that app under the
code nerdfitness
don't forget the code it's how they know
it's from us
speaking of door dash cheat meals eric
tommy
what are you going to reward yourself
with if you win the week
so i wanted some nice hot chicken
you know we got a great hot chicken we
got a bunch of great hot chicken places
around here in l.a
keep saying hot chicken hot chicken
tommy what are you looking for hot
chicken sounds delightful but i'm going
to have my chicken served hot as well
as it bathes in a pool of delicious
ramen broth
that's my sweet my noodles my bamboo
shoots my corn
my egg all of it one of you is gonna get
them the other one's gonna get a
delicious plate of vegetables or
something
but for now we're gonna keep on earning
it with today's workout let's get up
let's move come on guys
up up up up up
very dark in here once again yeah is
this a bat cave
guys it's time for another challenge
but why is it so dark in here because
this one's inspired by thor
the dark world oh you guys remember in
this movie thor battles malachite
and the rest of the dark elves he also
is learning to balance his
duty to the asgardian kingdom and his
love for a human woman
i've been there so you guys are gonna be
tested on your balance
by standing on a bosu ball while you try
to achieve your goal which is to destroy
more garden gnomes than your opponent
we couldn't find dark elves so it's okay
[Music]
but also that didn't feel hard enough
yet so then i was thinking
well you know how odin had to take on
the dark elves with only one eye
so you guys will be trying to destroy
them with eye patches ooh
destroy them how good question by
throwing [ __ ] hammers at them
so we gotta stand on balance balls
throwing hammers at gnomes with
no depth perception exactly
sick
[Music]
you ready you need any clarification no
other than why are you here what are you
doing here i'm going to coach you
okay and just in case you fail miserably
i'm also going to be recording
all right okay so if i knock over the
whole table i kind of win
by default right counting down three
two one destroy
she took it like i'm champion i'm trying
to do the odin growl
one down god of hammers
doing more damage to the hammers
well you know to kill my wife
there you go some real damage
all right and three two one
oh and you followed him all right how do
you think you did
uh i can't tell i i'm blind in this eye
oh that's your blind eye
all right you ready yeah let's do this
no more questions
yeah just throw the hammers at the dark
alps and to be clear
those are the dark elves yeah on the
camera dark elves no
these are very kind people that's where
i want you to focus your anger and
attention yep
no one else on set it's called a dark
elf
no are you ready yes all right take your
place
okay i'm gonna record this for the
inevitable trial
okay three two
one holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god
if you fall at the end of your turn
holy [ __ ]
philip there's one more and if you don't
mind i'd like to
try one last throw guys we can clear the
set this is a personal one for tommy
okay i'm done now damn y'all did some
damage
sometimes i assign other people's faces
to the gnomes faces
wasn't that right philip so yes very
clearly tommy destroyed
way more dark elves but eric still has a
chance of winning the week one i go back
and i look to see if they did their
workouts and stuck to their diet all
week long
and then i'll pick who the actual winner
of that sweet sweet door dash g meal is
you're looking good eric thanks tommy
four weeks in i like what i see
happy sunday boys great work at the
challenge
tommy it is very clear that you have
something personal against
elves or garden gnomes or some person
we did have to turn that footage over to
the fbi by the way oh they'll just put
it in their archives they've got lots of
footage of me
like another tommy one huh added to the
list
we love these we do marathons eric
you wanted some hot fried chicken this
week a tommy you wanted some nice ramen
to
suck on or suck up slurp on that's what
i'm thinking of
now uh why don't you guys go to your
door you guys should have doordash uh
delivery drivers there waiting with your
cheat meal or not cheat meal
okay now while they go get their meals
i'll let you know
that regarding who won the week tommy
definitely won the challenge
but they both had pretty solid exercise
weeks
so keep in mind this week i factored in
how many more calories each of them were
burning
than the previous week i've got those
numbers up on screen right now
which means our overall winner of the
week
is
[Music]
tell me what you got there buddy
ah look at that oh that's gorgeous
oh it's glowing eric uh what's that you
got there buddy
broccoli and other vegetables i see some
carrots too
yeah how carrots what an
easy nice snack to have yeah well enjoy
that
stew while you can tommy because next
week is captain america winter soldier
in guardians of the galaxy my favorite
two
marvel movies and uh whatever the
challenge is
i think i have you on them i can't even
hear that right now because i'm just in
ramen paradise
been spending most of my life living in
a ramen
paradise all right guys that's it for
this episode of fitness origins keep the
comments coming
also please share this show and please
use the doordash code it makes
a huge difference nerdfitness alright
give it up for our boys they had a great
week i've been philip molina and i'll
see you next time on fitness origins
look i i made a dick oh cute
now you've got one got him
you too noodle dick
fair
[Music]
you